by then it's gonna be focusing on the
real-time decision making applications
for the data collection processing at
LHC and a second part of this talk is
more machine learning aspects and I
presume how to get on top of everything
and stay ahead of everything moving down
the road hopefully and what to do if you
start behind yeah okay great so so we
had a really excellent introduction to
the whole set up from from Catarina so I
won't repeat all that but I'll just very
briefly motivate once again while we're
doing all this so at if you know super
high-level science at the LHC the idea
is they want to study the structure of
the smallest building blocks of matter
so to do that we build a giant a giant
microscope and you can think of ble to
use a microscope so here is my length
scale everything and on the length
scales we can see of course human eyes
are good enough for for doing
measurements but you want to go down to
10 to the minus 20 meters that's the
metric number for the distance scales
that were probing at the LHC you need
something like the Large Hadron Collider
and the experiments the Large Hadron
Collider and I'm gonna there many
experiments the LHC for big ones but I'm
gonna focus mostly on Atlas just as an
example but a lot of this applies more
generally okay so here is a slide you're
going to see several times which was
basically the pipeline for data analysis
collection as well as simulation and
both are going to be relevant for this
talk at the LHC so you've heard this
magic 40 megahertz number 25 nanoseconds
before so this is the rate at which
proton-proton collisions are happening
at the LHC and every clip every Bunch
crossing has about a hundred collisions
and those exit we only usual care one of
those next ones are called pileup and
I'll come back to that in a little bit
and the numbers here are in blue for
data and red for simulation so then you
have all the sub nuclear and nuclear
physics which spans many orders of
magnitude so 10 to the minus 20 after
10-15 one femtometer that is super super
fast and is basically not relevant on
the time scale of the real data but then
comes the slow part so the outgoing
particles interact the detector and the
particles are basically traveling at the
speed of light so the first detector
elements are
a past after about 0.01 nanoseconds and
then the time that the particles reach
the last parts of the detector is about
20 nanoseconds that's particles
traveling this bit of white all the way
through a detector that starts at a few
centimeters all the way out to meters
then you have a much lower effect from
the detector response so you have
basically particles traversing the
matter first thing our detector and
they're like ionization signals and
other simulation signals that are slow
and those can take up to 200 nanoseconds
so the numbers to compare with right are
these numbers compared with the 25
nanosecond number so we have bunch
crossings every 25 nanoseconds but it
takes longer than 25 nanoseconds to
propagate the whole signal through our
detector oh yeah yeah these part of all
the whole mix um I know but they're all
traveling so close to speed of light
that it basically doesn't matter for the
point of view of these numbers these
numbers assume everything going at the
speed of light these ones here there's
nothing magnetic field but I mean the
bending is is pretty small so these
numbers are like particles with a
relatively high energy typical high
energy going to the detector pretty
straight okay so so then after we have
this detector response we have to make a
decision we're gonna keep the event or
not so you here's when katarina we have
this first hardware level trigger which
we call usually level 1 and level 1 has
a few microseconds to decide if it keeps
the event or throws it away and then if
we keep the event we have a little bit
longer in software this huge software
form architecture to decide if we keep
the event or throw it away and once we
keep the event we reconstruct the event
so there's no we read out the whole
event and it's off detector and that
takes you know hundreds of microseconds
which is already pretty slow and then
okay at the end we do final data
analysis which you know people sitting
your laptop's discussing and meanings
this takes months and this may seem not
real time but numbers I want to keep in
your head are for the simulation steps
which I'll come back to you later in the
talk the sub-nuclear physics takes noma
seconds ah quitting particle
interactions detector takes minutes and
attack your response takes you hundreds
milliseconds this really dominated by
this part here material interactions so
if you think of it a minute per an event
i need billions of events pretty soon
you start getting on the timescale of
months oh so even months actually can be
real time and I'll come
what that means later okay the hardware
trigger has 2.5 microseconds but you're
getting 25 that's right
all the detector elements buffer and
depending on where you are you have
different amounts of events you store in
the buffer at a given time that's right
so what I'm gonna do is I want to throw
out this threw in this talk I want to
talk about various levels and how real
hard decision-making or adaptations of
fast analysis or fast algorithms can
play a role so let me start with a
detector response and there was some
discussion earlier about how we change
things both in hardware and software so
you've seen a picture like this before
I'm not gonna spend time talking about
it but hey our Collider based
high-energy physics expect I detect
those they're like onions well I should
say that I usually start this talk by
saying our detectors like onions
but my wife corrected me and so they're
not only like onions the more like leeks
okay so they're there there's still an
intrical so the protons are partly
coming this and there's a series of
detectors out as you go further and
further from the detector but the
biggest challenge for data rate is the
closer you are to the detector so the
biggest challenge is really innermost
layer so let me spend a couple of
minutes talking about the innermost
layers and the data challenges we have
there so here are some numbers here's a
the background is a pretty picture of
what an event might look like at the LHC
but you have a problem not only with the
occupancies this is like how many
particles hit our detector as a function
of time so 0.1 percent of our pixels are
our innermost layer we have a pixelated
detector are hit every time we have a
bunch crossing that's pretty high right
and then in terms of like the data rate
it sort of like streaming live audio
from each pixel okay it's pretty shitty
audio but okay I still it's a high rate
but the real challenge also is not just
high rate high occupancy but also we
have a thing in a high radiation
environment this is why a lot of we have
to do we do has to be customized we had
to build custom Asics and and custom
hardware because not only has to be
super fast it also has to be radiation
hard and here are just a table of
numbers to give you sense I don't look
at any of the numbers except the ones
I've highlighted in blue so once again
these are the that hit rates the readout
rates and the radiation damage and the
three different columns correspond to so
run one that was
until 2015 this is mm this is right now
run run two and run three and this is
what we're preparing for in the next in
ten years from now so we're going to
increase the rate by a factor of 10
going from here right now to here runs 4
& 5 very good so radiation has a has a
lot of causes a lot of problems for our
sensor elements so it actually can
degrade the sensors and any electronics
you can cause all sorts of problems you
can degrade the components as well as
cause single event upsets problems that
basically flip bits from zero to one and
make the readout easily not work yeah so
the radiation can cause our so all can
can really degrade our detector as a
time the irradiation is good right
because the radiation is more measuring
but it also can hurt our detector that's
right yeah so so flipping bits makes
your detector noisy or quiet and it also
can damage the components more systemic
long-term damage yeah but basically the
idea so as I was saying we need to put
custom a lot of custom components
because it is like having a super super
fast camera that also happens to be next
to nuclear reactor and unfortunately we
don't have any of these from from
industry so we have to do it ourselves
okay but we have good news which is that
on this inner most detector element both
Alison's he must have joined forces
which is not amazing to design custom
ASIC that will be used for the inner
most detector readout and actually well
a significant component of this design
is happening right here at Berkeley and
one of the spokespeople for this
collaboration is actually up on the hill
Maurice and I just showed a picture of
whether this is a current picture of our
prototype chef just to see that it
exists and we're currently doing some
testing with it
but I wanted to connect the design of
this ASIC with real-time decision-making
so in designing this hardware we have to
think how best we can both both readout
and you utilize the readout structure to
to have the best offline performance so
for instance one thing you had to think
about is that we don't read out single
pixels we read out regions and one the
reasons we reach out regions is because
you want to look for you want to help
recover hits that look low energy hits
that are next to big hits because big
kids are easier to define and so you
want ask the question like what's an
optimal
to read out so we can do a simple
algorithm like I might read out like a
2x2 pixel region or four by one pixel
region and it depends where you are on
your detector so you can think of our
pixel detector like this it's a bunch of
pixelated elements our proton collisions
happen here and we have some outgoing
particles and this ADA that's here is
basically the angle that you make with a
check to the vertical so a equals zero
is like straight up and it equals
infinite or a B equals large is is along
the beam line and as you go further out
basically you're you're traversing more
pixels in a row and therefore the
probability to have a neighboring pixel
fire is higher if you're if you're at a
higher angle you can use this
information to actually have a more
optimal readout region so in fact you
want the occupancy to be as high as
possible and you're in your readout
region although it's just wasting
redoubt bandwidth and so 2x2 is not as
good as 4 by 1 for my 1 the 4 is in a
long direction the direction where you
have more pixels that are hit so these
are kind of simple things we can think
about this is just a step the scene for
the kind of choices we can make while
optimizing a bit the redundant another
very important topic is not just what we
read out but how we read it out so in
the innermost layer for instance and all
the layers we read out there's some
analog signal and we convert it into a
digital signal and the innermost region
these pixel detectors we use an ADC
which is called time over a threshold is
super simple you have some analog signal
I take some in it you have some charge
deposit and it takes some time to
discharge in our capacitors we basically
just count how long are you over
threshold and we can buy long I mean we
count like these vertical dashed lines
or 25 nanosecond bunch crossings so
everything is tied to this 40 megahertz
clock but the LHC provides every one and
you can just simply ask how many punch
crossings are over threshold and that is
proportional to the charge that was
deposited this is very simple you know I
took the tott ot method but there's a
lot of choices we can make here for
instance how many bits do I record I can
actually sculpt I can have some
sculpting so I don't have to make it
linear charge the tott I can do I have
lots of choices here I just want to say
that we discharge information is
actually critically useful so offline
this T ot this charged information is
used for many purposes for instance that
you had charge information you can
do analog interpolation on the position
of hit so you can say I have some some
hit pixels if it's if I have more than
just binary readout I can figure out
where the particles were and that shows
the resolution basically improves when
you use charge information we also use
charge information for particle
identification because different
particles have different charge
signatures and we can also look inside
that pixel cluster and ask what their
more than one particle because more than
one particle would leave more charge
than if you had only one particle so
right now I'll be Alice attractor for
instance uses four bits of TOD I mean
your charger can charge two Tod
conversion scheme but we could ask the
question maybe this is not optimal and
we don't have to have the same readout
as we have record so you can imagine
reading with five bits and recording
with four bits or other schemes like an
doesn't have to be a linear down
sampling to do something more
complicated so we've done many many
studies but I just want to highlight one
possibility or you could imagine
I wanna compute the position resolution
is of my pixel clusters that's like
showing the vertical axis here
as a function of the number of bits I I
have but imagine I have a scheme where I
have a 5 bit counter and I haven't n bit
storage so I want to find what's the
best way of transferring 5 bits to 2n
bits and being Lopes police no bigger
than 5 and the position resolution here
like so the up is worse and so if I have
only one bits of 5 to 1 but it's the
same as having one bit to begin with but
if I have 5 bits
read out and 3 bits storage I can
actually improve quite a bit versus
having 3 bits read out 3 bit storage so
there are many schemes here that
actually might allow us to have some
faster algorithms and hardware that are
then down sampled in the actual what's
actually read out so it's a loss lossy
read out but it actually might improve
things if we if we cleverly design the
electronics and there many more
considerations like this that are we're
currently studying in the in the design
of these a sex because we're going to
have to now iterate a few times before
we go into production mode for designs
new detector
single event but in a you know capture
Muniz you've got multiple events is
there a way to have them all kind of
talk to each other so that a bad
resolution systemically off here is
effectively corrected by you know
another particle direction yeah so here
it's a bit complicated because we're
talking about very local information at
basically the bunch crossing rate so
this is in hardware and it doesn't it's
not able to it can know about the
neighbors basically but not things that
are far away you're post-processing yes
saw it so offline you can use it you can
use all the available information to
improve the resolution but if we throw
away information here so a friends if
I'm gonna record with three bits that
information is lost forever I can never
recover more yeah but maybe I can do a
clever scheme in the hardware where I
have a five bit counter but a 3 bit
writer which is effectively better than
regular in a three bit counter okay so
that's all I want to say for now just to
give you a taste for this this detector
response and now I'm going to move to
another topic so a little bit slower
time scale which is this the hardware
based trigger I heard a lot about this
in Caterina's talk and one of the main
messages was the was that you've seen
you even saw a pot like this which is
that the cross sections the production
of things at the LHC are dominated by
kind of boring well let's say usually
thought of as boring a kind of event
that have no electrons no muons no
neutrinos and why these things are
interesting is because we collide
protons and then we we might want to
look for rare things like electrons
muons neutrinos so so the rate is really
dominated by no electrons no nuan's
donor tree knows all the interesting
stuff down here has electrons muons and
neutrinos so not surprisingly the
recorded events are dominated by
electrons muons and neutrinos so here
you can see the this is the software
trigger rate the basically that the
total bandwidth is this is the top and
you can see how it's decomposed into
various categories so this is a similar
version of the plot that Katarina showed
and that the whole bandwidth here is
weakly dominated by the electrons and
you'ens and other electromagnetic we
interacting particles whereas the just
like the quarks and gluons
production which are these these blue
colors here are much smaller fraction so
that means that all those events that
were uninteresting are heavily pre
scaled maybe throw away a lot of them
randomly so the usual paradigm which is
that if your favorite process is not
triggered on it's not recorded and you
lose it forever there are some new
paradigms so one possible way around
this is to look for your favorite
process produce an association with
something else and then you can trigger
onto something else and then look at the
thing you like another possibility
that's this guy called The Associated
production mechanism and other one which
is this trigger level analysis is to do
your analysis faster and to do it in in
the actual trigger yes that Association
is this for a particular collision
that's right that's the key point yeah
so I have proton proton collision button
they see one of the protons as their
cladding radiated something so I can
trigger on the radiator thing and then
look for something else yeah okay so I
want to talk about maybe a possibly for
a new paradigm because these have
problems so one is that there's a large
effective prescale by requiring this
extra thing produced the cross-section
for the extra thing is very small so you
pay a large price and in the trigger
level analysis case you pay a cost which
is that you still have to pass the
hardware trigger you can never beat the
hardware trigger so all your analysis
still happens at the software trigger
and usually the harsher penalty is in
the hardware trigger so what can we do I
told you that we don't collide single
protons at a time we collide many
protons at at times order 100 protons so
imagine you have this is like a zoom in
of the put the proton proton collision
axis is like this one and we're zooming
in really really small here you can see
we can actually reconstruct individual
proton-proton collisions this is one
bunch crossing and we have many proton
collisions so let's say for instance you
trigger on the pink one from electrons
all the other you know one hundred minus
one collisions are unbiased there's zero
bias and they in principle can have
interesting physics in them so the idea
is what if you trigger it on the pink
and use all the other colors to look for
interesting physics so we call this a
zero bias trigger and you can ask the
question what is the effective preschool
from the zero bias trigger
so the amount of data I have from this
looking at the other collision idea is
the regular triggered data that you have
multiplied by the trigger rate divided
by the total proton proton bunch
crossing so 40 40 megahertz is what the
collision rate happens and then we can
if we do the analysis offline
it's the HLT offline software right if I
do the analysis online then we pay the
hardware level an analysis rate and here
are some representative numbers so you
found the number of collisions you have
this is what we have you know roughly
right now the numbers that I think you
heard also before is that so one
kilohertz is basically right out to tape
right now and so that means your
effective prescale from the zero bias
data set would be something like 10 to
the 4 if you do the analysis offline and
400 if you do the analysis in the in the
software trigger and this is really
important because this is like a lower
limit basically you don't have to worry
I think there's a question earlier what
if you just didn't record the thing you
were looking for this is that don't
worry you always have some large
fraction of 0 bias data that you did
record because you triggered on
something else and you can look in these
other collision which are totally
written out to tape and so this is this
is the upshot basically if you have a
zero background search and you can't be
a trigger with a deficiency of 0.02
percent you should be using this zero
bias data looking at the pileup
collisions and you can do the analysis
fast in software basically that number
goes up to one percent so that's not so
bad
and here is just a plot that shows a
comparison between the effective
preschool as a function of the object
energy energy this is the effective
preschool so a higher number means you
throwing away more events randomly one
means you save everything the blue is if
your associate
object is a photon and the writers of
your associated object is a quark-gluon
and as Katharina said we have higher pre
scales for quarks and gluons the pre
scale for those that are like you know
400 in these units GeV and for photons
is a bit lower but in it but in both
cases so the black solid line here if
you do this zero bias trigger off line
and they're the dashed line if you do it
online so you actually can get a
significant improvement over these
standard techniques by
using the data that you already took but
not the data you were thinking we should
look at it was the upshot get this huge
it asset that we're currently ignoring
new physics might be hiding in these
data and its most powerful when
combining with a trigger level analysis
actually so you at level one and the
hardware you trigger on say electrons
and then it software you look at say
jets that Katarina mentioned but this
requires designing the algorithms now
because they have to be if they don't
they're not in the software then they're
at the lost forever
and I think that the key takeaway
message that the the bottom line for any
analysis the at the LHC is not zero so
if you don't trigger on it you're not
totally hosed you still have a you still
have a line which is much bigger than
zero so that's good news and I think
there the creativity I think the key
point is that the the the sky and not
the trigger it's really the limit when
it comes to doing analysis limited by
trigger okay so now I want to move on
and go a little bit further down on this
timescale ladder to to focusing now on
improvements that one could use the
software-based trigger decision and also
have entry construction so here the
machine learning will start coming in
and once again I'm going to talk about
pile up so this pile up is really a key
issue at the LHC because the pileup is a
source of noise so sometimes the pileup
has interesting events but most of the
time the pileup is just soft energy
that's scattered everywhere randomly on
our event and that distorts and degrades
the trigger performance as well as all
of our offline reconstruction algorithms
this is very similar to an image des
noising problem where I have noise that
are some randomly put on top of my image
I think of my detector as an image very
multi stack layer image that has a high
granularity we can use machine learning
for image denoising however our meters
are kind of interesting looking images
so here's a kind of a pretty plot that
shows five to my protons collide I have
my particles go out this is the surface
of my detector and I I measure some so
energy deposits say but the this pilot
is kind of interesting because as you
saw from earlier slides I can
reconstruct the vertices of all the
collisions so if a particle if particles
from pileup are charged and I can
reconstruct their trajectories I know if
their pileup are and
because I can point them back to a
vertex so it's a kind of noise this pile
up is a kind of noise ride no part of it
exactly I know the charge part of the
noise by know nothing about the neutral
part of the noise so that suggests an
algorithm where I have three images that
I want to use for denoising I have the
image from the collision I care about
but there's the charged one because I
can pick out the charged parts that's
what I call the leading vertex charged I
have the charged from the noise which I
can also identify very well that's the
pileup charged and then I have the
neutral total for the sum of the one I
care about and all the noise and the
idea is to use these three images to
predict an image which is the collision
I care about the neutral part of the
collision I care about Alex Lee
completes the picture and once I have
that one I can also compute the noise
image if I really cared about it so you
can do is very simply treat think of
this as an RGB image and then do
regression the image based regression so
I take my RGB image I apply some
convolutional neural networks or other
modern machine learning techniques and I
output another image and that's like
schematically shown here so my input RGB
image do some machine learning and the
output is another image event by event
this
three channel image denoising I mean pre
channel image denoising have been done
for decades without necessarily having
to resort to this yeah definitely
definitely so there's a couple a couple
of points so one is that our images are
very big so convolutional comments when
that works are useful because of course
I can have small convolution of filter
sizes for enormous images that are say
thousands of thousands by thousands so
they're convolutions they're very
powerful but in terms of like modern
machine learning techniques there are a
lot of tricks in training these networks
that are very good at identifying the
soft subtle features of our images that
are just much better than all their
techniques and I'll show the performance
in this a second yeah okay so here it's
like a pot that shows this a performance
metric of how well this machine learning
does and here I want to show so this is
a one possible metric which is we have
some objects that we can reconstruct
from an image and they have some mass
and the mass is a really important
physical quantity we want to be able to
reconstruct well so this is the the mass
after applying some correction from
pilot for pileup divided by the true
reconstructed mass so this is what we
did this is in simulation so I can know
the right answer and I do leave this
this this region would be a delta
function at 1 as a comparison between
the blue yellow and black are different
algorithms and these blue and yellow are
sort of state-of-the-art physics based
algorithms and I won't apologize for my
colleagues who can't with their names I
don't know why one is called soft killer
one is called puppy so to follow suit we
called our algorithm pummel pileup with
machine learning and the point is that
the black distribution is more centered
at want and more peaked so that's a good
sign suggest as doing something
intelligent with respects to the other
techniques which are basically
engineered by hand and the idea here is
you have a fully automated way of
optimizing the pilot mitigation but we
can do we can go a bit further and just
to give you a kind of another sense of
how well this does this plot shows the
correlation between the corrected mass
and the true mass in simulation as a
function of the number of extra particle
proton-proton collisions in my event so
the more extra collisions the more noise
so basically more noises to the right
less noises to the left and ideally it
would be correlation coefficient of 1 so
we'd be able to exactly get the true
value and you can see the the
state-of-the-art the blue and the yellow
they degrade a bit a decrease so they're
getting worse the more noise you have it
is expected and also the machine
learning one also gets worse the more
noise you have but the key point is that
the black and the gray are higher than
the other ones and also flatter another
very interesting feature is that it
between black and Gray's where they're
trained the gray is trained with a
hundred and forty extra collisions but
tested everywhere whereas the black is
trained with twenty and trained and
tested everywhere and you can see that
as expected it the ones that are trained
at a particular place do better than
that was not trained there but they're
still relatively flat and pretty close
so that suggests that the algorithm is
learning something Universal about this
pilot that has nothing to do with not
particularly but that energy scale that
they were trained at but they can be
applied more generally not necessarily
to maintain any quantitative correct
values about the pixels absolutely
there's something which I haven't shown
you which is what the images look like
so our images look nothing like natural
images our majors have almost no
features the very sparse and they're
highly noisy looking just even the even
the signal looks very noisy so there's
no edges for instance so it makes it
very difficult yes traditional
algorithms are designed for natural
images
they're not designed to preserve any
quantitative values yes this yeah this
will come up also in the next topic
which is that in you know in in the
science domain we have like clear
quantitative things you want to want to
be good so here like the mass
correlation is a number I can quantify
and try to optimize although I care
about lots of things not just the mass
but indeed so if you're training it to
optimize the mass then how does it how
well does it preserve the other thing
that you care that are your questions we
have done that yet but in principle so
we've I just showed the mass but we've
looked at like dozen or so observables
that we care about in principle and the
the metric is a standard loss function
on the image so it doesn't actually know
about mass we could in principle impose
that it also preserves the mass and
presumably we do a bit better I don't
have the plot to show you there's like a
dozen herself yeah
are you also regularizing with any
physics at all is you just do pure
commnets you're not saying that well so
there's only the only physical input
well there's a lot of physical input met
with training samples have a lot of many
years of physics but but the only
physical input is that is the loss
itself we know something about the
pileup is generally low energy so we
have structure the loss function such
that it penalizes we want to preserve
high-energy stuff more than look below
at low energy stuff other than that
there's basically no physical regulation
yeah okay so by improving this pileup we
can improve the the effect performance
both at the trigger level the software
trigger level and offline and one nice
feature about these algorithms is that
confidence for instance are relatively
simple to apply fast in a fast way
and also can be applied for instance in
an in nice grid form in your images in a
nice grid form which is what our trigger
level objects look like so this I think
is a really key application to apply it
also in the in the trigger level okay so
the last topic which I think I'll spend
the most time talking about is about
this number which is the biggest number
on this slide which is the interaction
of the outgoing particles with our
detector that takes minutes to simulate
so it took you know a long time say
after 20 nanoseconds to happen
physically but the simulation can be
extremely slow
and I'll make the connection so this is
not necessarily for real-time
decision-making but as I'll come to
later we need real-time speed in order
to do this effectively I think that's
what I say here so yeah so so it's not
real-time decisions but if we don't have
fast algorithms then this is just not
gonna work because this number might
seem small I don't care about a minute
but a minute times a billion is a lot of
minutes so then then we start to compete
with this this a timescale here and
there's actually can be a limiting
factor in analyses so let me first
review for you a little bit how
simulation works at the LHC so this is a
schematic of what an event might look
like it's definitely not to scale so you
have like 10 to the minus 20 meters is
over here and then this is like a
detector over here which is like meters
away and the the only way we can span 10
to the minus 20 up to one meter is is I
carefully considering all the physical
components and just to say like as I
said this took it this can take a minute
per man for the whole thing but the real
key is that it's possible because of a
factorization so yeah technically maybe
it's like the markov property which is
that we can simulate all the different
length scales in sequence so once you
seem you like one length scale and once
you seem like you know that the n plus 1
Planck scale you don't care what the N
minus one place scale it only depends on
what came before it and this so
basically we do is we have a stack of
simulators and the slowest simulators
when I want to spend the most time
talking about but but there's a many
many simulators and most of them are
very fast so let me start by saying the
first level simulator that we call the
hard scatter so basically you start at
the very beginning you give the
simulator the equations of motion which
looks something like this and there are
many tools that exist for basically
doing phase space integrals against
these equations of motion and they
produce say outgoing quarks and gluons
which are the smallest length scales
probed in a simulation so 10 to the
minus 20 meters then take the output of
that simulation and you feed it to
another simulation which takes those
hard high-energy quarks and gluons and
turns those into protons and other
particles like protons things we can
actually measure and this simulation is
also not a limiting factor it's
to be fast in many a very nice and
efficient algorithms for doing that but
then what happens next is those
particles hit our detector so you have
these charged particle tracks and you
have depositions and say our calorimeter
which with these big blob is what's
represent and the state of the art for
material interactions this package
collagen for giant for I think is used
by many many fields for particle or
actions especially by impressed
especially in particle nuclear physics
and it includes a series of libraries
for detailed descriptions of nuclear
reactions electromagnetic interactions
of particles with matter and basically
you can there's a series of levels of
precision you can have more precision
that take longer and we have some
compromise at the LHC or we say we need
this level precision it takes I know
however much time it takes but the key
takeaway message is that this simulation
basically counts for an or one fraction
of all simulation or all not just in
uation all computing should be computing
computing resources at the LHC and in
general and half I think it's also a
lower one fraction now after the
particle interactions with the detector
there's another step which is what I
mentioned before that you actually have
to then digitize all the signals and so
after this giant simulation says this
much energy was deposited in this
particular detector element then we have
custom code to do digitization to turn
that into a you know the analog signal
to a digital signal and this is sort of
custom code by the various experiment
it's very fast and so usually is not
much of a concern you've seen this this
plot earlier I just want to mention it
here because there's an important point
which is that calorimeter energy
deposits factorize in the sense that if
I have you know four particles
depositing energy in a calorimeter the
energy that is deposited is the sum of
the energies from each particle but the
digitisation this detector electronic
smell that kind of modeling is not
linear so noise for instance nonlinear
thresholds these these impose some
effects which cannot be modeled by
factorizing the deposition of energy
from all the particles yes
so what's what's the model of the
detector with a different detector so
it's a very complicated nuclei sort on
average or well sight so you say like we
have a very detailed geometry model or
detector that says there's silicon right
here then above the silicon there's a
little strip of aluminum because we have
electronics and then and then we have
many of those segmented and when a
particle goes through this giant
detector literally radiates part like
you know low-energy ionization energy or
scintillation energy depend on what's
going through off of the initial
particle so you're modeling particle
debris electron cloud interaction yeah
exactly so the particle like so this
thing later might say this the the
particle deposited you know say 10 ke v
of energy at this point in space and
then we turn that into electron hole
pairs and then we probably at the
electron hole pairs through the silicon
and we record it so it's very detailed
yeah very detailed modeling of all the
really the low-level some parts that are
empirical some parts are physically
physical what's all physically motivated
but a lot of its empirical yeah
but it's supposed to work it works for
all elements so it's really amazing this
this the software packet is used also
for like medical imaging where you can
you can you can also shoot particles
like protons into skin and things like
that and it's a different kind of
modeling from the collision original
collision
yes so so this Jam model is totally
different than the other the other
simulators I talked about earlier yeah
yeah that's right
yeah as opposed to like honey like yeah
yeah detail high energy physics yeah
okay great so so my goal for the
remainder of this talk is basically to
talk about how we can replace or augment
simulation steps with faster powerful
generators based on severe machine
learning techniques and basically there
are many steps we could try to speed up
I just told you about all of them but
the believer the lowest hanging fruit is
to attack the slowest part which is the
interaction of particles in a
calorimeter and why is the caliber of
the slowest because what's the point of
a calorimeter the commoners to stop the
particles so easily have like an
electron hits a calorimeter I try to
stop it so to stop it has to radiate a
lot of particles there's a very detailed
interactions of those particles inside
the detector volume whereas for tracking
detective like a piece of silicon if I
shoot an electron through the silicon
its head low at low ionization and so
there's only a little bit of energy
deposited there it's relatively fast to
simulate so maybe I just may be quickly
say like why you should care so many
analyses at the moment are basically
you're forced to use this jeon basting
later because we have fast simulators
not good enough and I just just for
comparison I show you this is the same
polish that earlier but this is three
three billion events this is the
cross-section of particle collision and
this is three billion events at the
upgraded LHC the one we're gonna have in
ten years
so everything below here is more rare
than one in a billion so if you want to
have a background and same number of
background events simulated as you do in
your detector you're gonna have to seem
like more than three billion events now
we're more clever than just generating
three billion you know proton-proton
collisions but this just sets the scale
for how many kind of events you need I
mean even at this point right W bosons
are you know in the billions of events
and we're gonna have one record most of
the W boson events so we need to
simulate also a lot of W boson notes
okay yeah so this is just my my warning
if we don't do something basically won't
be able to do data analysis at the
upgraded LHC and if you do something now
we can save a lot of money which makes
people happy okay so how can how can
machine learning help so training neural
networks is very slow I think people
here who have trained neural networks
you know they can take days to weeks to
train the kernel network especially a
complicated one physics based simulators
are also very slow but evaluation time
of neural network is extremely fast so
if I can train a neural network to learn
my physics based simulator
I can then have a surrogate simulator
that's extremely fast to evaluate and
see what I want to do with Loren had
generate showers in the calorimeter
with a neural network okay so how does
it work there are many possibilities for
turning a neural network into a
generator but this is a very
particularly powerful one that's a
relatively recent idea called a
generative adversarial neural network
and the idea is what is a generator a
generator is nothing other than a map a
function between noise and stuff you
care about so I make one of those let me
get a null Network so I have a generator
network a generator network that Maps
noise to images images being like my
calorimeter energy deposits I have
another network that classifies this
image as being from the generator or
from the physics based model and they
compete against each other so this one
tries to generate realistic looking
images and my other one tries to tell if
they're from the the neural network or
from the physics based simulator and
when this one is totally confused when
it can't tell if it's from the physics
based simulator or from the generator
then the generator is really good and
that's the idea how do you train these
kind of things okay but it's more
complicated because we don't just have
single layers so this is a kind of a
schematic view of what our one of our
color motors the Atlas detector looks
like so you see a particle might go
through here and hit through and go
through three layers but you might
notice that first of all these three
layers don't have the same granularity
so the pixelation is different in all
three layers that's a key complication
but it is not a complication which is
that the particle energy the the energy
spectrum in this calendar layer depends
on the energy spectrum in this commodore
energy layer so it's basically like a
short movie and that makes it also kind
of complicated but we have a model for
doing this and I just very quickly flash
up my our neural network design looks
like and I don't wanna go through all
the all the pieces here but basically
you feed in the neural network the
energy of the particle the type of
particle so you say I want a app ion
that has 10 GB of energy and then what
we do is we generate one image I'm not
gonna talk about this Logan is a method
for doing locally connected instead of
convolutional layers but it's basically
a convolutional neural network and then
to match it to the next layer we resize
that image so we take our output of our
first generated image resize it and then
we have another randomly sampled image
and we combine the two so we combine the
first image the second one this gives us
some causality between images and then
we do the same thing for the third layer
so they have another layer which is
combined with the output of the second
layer to give us a third layer and that
generates three images and those three
images are suppose to correspond to one
kellerman or shower and I can of course
ask the network to give me many many
showers I'm not gonna see the
architecture for the discriminator but
the idea is kind of similar just in
Reverse okay
so this is what it looks like
generate many many showers so the top
row here are the average images for a 10
GB electron for the physics-based
emulator and the first second and third
layers of this liquid argon calorimeter
and these are the images the average
images from our neural network and this
remember this is called a generative
adversarial network so it's called again
and this is for a kilometer so we call
it callaghan we can look in more detail
modest about averages because of course
the averages are important we all need
to get the fine details of the
distributions correct and there are many
many more plots one can look at but it
turns out it's actually of course very
hard to look visualize the space in say
a thousand dimensions you have a 30 by
30 image then very quickly becomes very
large but we can take slices and
dimensions that we know are rather
important so for instance is the energy
deposit in the first layer and here
there many lines that correspond to the
physics based simulator there's the
field histograms for electrons photons
and charged ions and then the same for
our generator our neural network based
generator and you can see there's a
qualitative agreement between the
various shapes which is very good but of
course there's also certain for
improvement so you see some features
that are present and say there no
network that are not present in the net
physics-based emulator I'm serious
there's clearly room for improving upon
which shown here but I really like this
plot because of course the generator
doesn't know about the net internal
doesn't know about this shower shape it
knows about the full thousand
dimensional space and you know
qualitatively reproduces this this image
in fact one could actually input this
image into the neural network to impose
that it learns this one well as was
discussed earlier with the mass but for
now it's used to hold out to do
validation but in principle I could I
could force it to learn this well in the
training of a neural network but this is
really about the punch line in the punch
line as I said I started by motivating
this all about speed so I have to it has
to perform well but it also has to
perform well fast so here's the physics
based simulator and this is how long it
takes to generate one kilometer shower
for some hardware on CPU and I thought
you use the same CPU
to generate my one shower in the
callaghan that's from this number to
this number you see it's much much
faster so that's good news that's how I
started by motivating this whole thing
in the family and you can actually gain
by batching so instead generating one
shower at a time you
many showers and you actually don't lose
that much you actually gain a bit in
speed and a typical event at the LHC
might have a thousand particles going
out so you might need to enter a
thousand showers at a time so this is a
relevant relative in relevant realistic
number of course you can also gain from
GPU so if you get a GPU and this is the
number of 4,000 you see I really is a
lot to gain here so me five orders of
magnitude and this isn't quite fair
because of course CPU so giant on CPU of
this number will continue to get better
and CPUs for networks will continue to
get better but this just gives you a
rough idea there are significant gains
and time that seem possible with protec
Niek like these generative ever scaling
networks to Port Jim for to Jay P you
there is an effort and there's also an
effort to take techniques like the
general adversity all networks and port
them into giant so there's this giant
five project which is this the successor
of Gen 4 there's many ongoing projects
both on the regular it's a regular
standard giant part to speed it up as
well as denigrating machine learning
into various components okay so that
brings me to the end so the other two is
really a unique science tool with
extreme challenges and a lot of those
challenges really into the data rate and
we need both real-time decision-making
solutions but also real time algorithms
for offline that allow that empower the
science to happen I think there many
exciting opportunities for new ideas to
fully exploit our data and we have to do
this because we need to make sure that
no stone goes unturned will not have
another LHC and so we need to make sure
that we really fully exploit the data
analysis that we have it are at our
hands
take any further questions - one
comments but the gans that we're
concerned about we love these devices
but they have this problem that in
principle that generator can generate
data in an subspace of the true data
space as long as it's doing a good job
and when the promises with your space is
thousands or millions of dimensions
there could be some kind of fractal
subspace so in any projection it looks
good but in fact you're only seeing some
part of the data subspace and I think
that's an open question that almost all
scientific uses of Gans absolutely so
we've done some tests to try to probe
for instance if it's memorizing or if
it's only looking at a sub so it doesn't
have the same entropy as the original
data set so you can do some tests for
instance we're looking at the nearest
neighbors in within sample and outside
of samples what these plots are supposed
to show we say look at the nearest
neighbor the nearest giant image or the
nearest scan image and they're about the
same distribution so that's that's a
good sign to suggest that it's not
memorizing nor is it no and also has the
same entropy as the original original
data but this is a key challenge as you
said for us we have a interesting task
because we have really good fastening
leaders already and those fast
simulators they also we know exactly
what subsets what like manifold they
live on because they're just Gaussian
they're like multi-dimensional gaussians
and so the first thing to do is to try
to beat them to see if we are at least
doing as well as those things and then
we can try to go extend beyond that and
try to match higher dimensional features
that those generators by construction
can't handle one other one other comment
or whatever question is you're you are
sitting you're putting him again at the
very high level like very late in GM so
you're saying you do get a chance to do
the whole thing in the new se can i
reproduce the whole thing
Gyan there's particular sub-modules in
GM that are taking all the cpu you could
run your machine learning there and
replace modules GM within that like in
the climate world I think that's what
people are thinking yeah so in fact
we've thought about I mean so we made
some choice here about what's up to what
step to do it so it's an end and in
terms of Jeon and you couldn't principle
for instance do have some kind of
network that learns like like a
recurrent kind of finding out learn is
like all the energy depositions that it
as it goes like the shower propagate so
then you only have to learn like the
part that that like the kernel basically
that that's yeah and become that becomes
kind of complicated very quickly because
there's lots of physics models in jail
that dependent you become like you can
become detector agnostic which is good
so this is detector not detector
diagnostic it depends a lot on the
structure of our calculator but if you
learn in the court like the actual
probability distributions inside Jeon
then you can be detector agnostic which
is very powerful and I think something
like that will be where the full gains
are gonna be realized but for a
particular experiment if I know I have
yeah this experiment then I can try to
gain by training exactly on that I think
you're anything at this in terms of
modifying your loss function so that you
get the correct distribution of types of
events but is isn't a generator or the
the discriminator now just basically
looking
pants and trying to say are you real or
you're not rather than looking over the
entire distribution so so the lots of it
through the discriminator acts on
individual events but the loss is in a
batch level and so what we have so this
is the discriminator Network now and so
you have your your your input images and
we have some convolutional locally
connected but they're only convolutional
layers to process them but then we have
mini batches criminais ssin because
exactly exactly the point that you just
look at individual images and the loss
then you won't we produce the data
entropy because you only can see in
digital examples but here you look at an
ensemble a batch of examples all at once
and you have some features which are at
the batch level that also go into the
loss in so your to the game distribution
gun again you get close but it won't
exactly correspond to the true
distribution yeah
so for what sort of application is that
about
it's your question so the real question
now is is this better than the current
fast simulators this is like a system so
the way the current fasteners work is
that like I was mentioning earlier
basically a bunch of gaussians that are
sampled in a space like in these spaces
for instance that we know are important
and they miss higher dimensional
correlations in the data and we can
first of all compare with those and
these techniques or systemizing approval
so the problem with the fasting raters
right now is you have if you want to add
a new feature you have to manually
change how things are set up this will
get better if like someone has a new
idea for how to improve Gann training
this benefits directly from that so we
have to first beat the fast meters and
the real problem with fasting waiters
right now is that the current Atlas and
C minus two experiments they're
fasteners are proprietary so it's
extremely hard to compare this unless
you implement this in the full Atlas say
software framework which we're doing but
you have to convince 3,000 people with
an aging code base that something new
like this should be implemented and that
takes a lot of work and that that's
happening and that that's where the key
comparison will happen first it's a look
at the standard observables that people
use to train the current fasting later
and then to look at higher dimensional
features say in a physics analysis
that's particularly sensitive to the
shower modeling
questions alright let's thank Ben again
one